today on the show we'll discuss the
continued bastardization and degradation
of Christianity by the media and the
political class also 5 headlines
including one of the best questions I've
ever heard anybody ask at one of these
town hall meetings with it with a
politician usually you get a bunch of
terrible questions pointless questions
this was a very good question so we'll
play that and I'm canceling Reuters
today I think this might be the second
time I've canceled them in in in in just
a week or two but you know they I keep
canceling them they keep coming back
they're like a a turd that won't flush
and if you know what movie that quote is
from we can be best friends and finally
some emails telling me why I'm wrong
always my favorite kinds of emails all
of that on the way but first a new
sponsor joins the show today excited
about that liquid IV now look believe it
or not a lot of people end up more
dehydrated in the winter months than
they do in the summer months which is
what you expect but cold weather makes
dehydration harder to spot also
you-you-you don't expect that you'll get
dehydrated as you don't you don't feel
yourself needing that the the liquid
quite as much so you're less likely to
keep refilling your water but water
bottles and if you're traveling you know
dehydration makes jetlag and headaches
even worse thankfully there's liquid ivy
the fastest most efficient way to stay
hydrated liquid IV is the fastest
growing wellness brand and you can find
them everywhere these days are all over
the place and they contain this is this
is this is what you're getting contains
five essential vitamins more vitamin C
than an orange and has as much potassium
as a banana so you're getting all of
that all those vitamins you need plus
you're getting the hydration now I'm a
I'm one of those people I'm like I am
constantly telling the people around me
that you got to stay hydrated it's like
I'm a broken record with it
I'm always telling us - my wife who has
a for some reason she's one of those
people doesn't like water she always
talked about how she does how do you not
like water well if you don't like water
if you're one of those one of those
weirdos this is also a solution for you
because liquid IV it also tastes great
so you know you're getting that that
hydration you're getting the vitamins
tastes great you're getting everything
you need but this is this is the
solution to a lot of problems you don't
think it would solve is just simply
staying hydrated
you feel tired you're feeling worn down
a lot it might be that you're just not
hydrated so you can get 25% off when you
go to liquid IV com use code Walsh at
checkout that's 25% off anything you
order our liquid IV just go to liquid IV
com enter promo code walls to save 25%
off and get better hydration starting
now that's liquid IV calm promo code
Walsh don't wait start properly
hydrating today so okay we've gotten
used to the left's mangling of
Christianity but a few examples in
recent days are especially egregious so
I think they're worth worth looking at
first here's Alexander Kaiser Cortese at
a hearing speaking as she claims as a
woman of faith experience he was hearing
and I'm struggling whether I respond or
launch into this question as a
legislator or from the perspective of a
woman of faith it's very difficult to
sit here and listen to arguments in the
long history of this country
of using scripture and weaponizing and
abusing scripture to justify bigotry
white supremacists have done it those
who justified slavery did it those who
fought against integration did it and
we're seeing it today and sometimes
especially in this body I feel as though
if Christ himself walked through these
doors and said what he said thousands of
years ago that we should love our
neighbor and our enemy that we should
welcome the stranger fight for the least
of us that it is easier for a rich man
it's easier for a camel to go through
the eye of a needle than for a rich man
to get into a kingdom of heaven he would
be maligned as a radical and rejected
from these doors and it is part of my
faith that all people are holy
and all people are sacred
unconditionally okay stop it stop it
right there because I I can't I just
can't as the kids would say I can't I
don't even know what I can I simply can
here we have a supporter of abortion
through every stage of pregnancy with no
limits at all
saying that all people are sacred
well aoc maybe you can explain this one
to me tell me if all people are sacred
are they sacred inherently or do they
earn their sacredness over time by by
degree as they grow how does it work
exactly is it is the sacredness
conditioned on their location with
respect to the womb is a conditioned on
their development is that is it
conditioned on their on their ability to
care for themselves I mean what is it
conditioned on well you said no it's
it's unconditional
you said sacred unconditional now if
that's the case if we as people are
unconditionally sacred then we must be
sacred in the womb and if we are how do
you justify dismember a sacred being and
throwing it in a dumpster or selling its
parts like it's an old Chevy or
something
tell me explain your theory of human
sacredness because I don't quite
understand it you can't explain it
because you're a hypocrite babbling
you're using your alleged faith as a
cudgel as a battering ram to advance
your political ends which is exactly
what you accuse your opponents of doing
but it's exactly what you're doing here
and you're doing it hypocritically
because you don't really believe that
that's what hypocrisy is as I've
explained many times hypocrisy is not
simply saying one thing and doing
another we all are guilty of doing that
hypocrisy is saying something you don't
really believe and I don't believe that
anybody on the left
in modern times could possibly actually
believe that all people are sacred
that's that's
position that the pro-lifers hold you
want to and I agree with it people are
sacred we have dignity that's the right
position it's also a position that's
inherently appealing to everybody
of course we Walt we all want to believe
that we have dignity well if you want to
hold that view you better go over to the
pro-life side because that is the
logical conclusion of a belief that all
people have inherent dignity and
synchronism meanwhile we have a number
of people attacking Mike Pence as usual
so this is okay so this is the that's
that's another example and we get this
you know several times a week often from
people who judge but he's out of the
picture now so now AOC is gonna pick up
a torch of somebody on the left using
faith hypocritically cynically to
advance their political ends so we've
got that and we've also got the left
degrading and heaping scorn and mockery
on faith you know those two strategies
are actually contradictory you kind of
have to choose one or the other because
if faith is a stupid silly ridiculous
thing that only dummies partaken then
you can't also use it to make a point
can you so meanwhile we have people
attacking Mike Pence as usual Mike Pence
is attacked all that Mike Pence is the
most hated man in Washington even more
than Donald Trump despite the fact that
he hasn't done anything does it well
vice presidents don't do much in general
so that's no knock on Mike Pence but he
hasn't done anything really as a vice
president to earn this scorn he's not
out there at Gay Pride rallies preaching
fire and brimstone you know in into into
a speaker he's not out there with a
bullhorn shouting fire and brimstone
despite how the left two portrays him
that's not actually what he's doing but
any case thereafter Mike Pence now
because he's heading up the coronavirus
task force and he made the mistake of
praying so here's a tweet that has
18,000 likes currently it's a picture of
Pence and his team heads bowed in prayer
and the caption says Mike Pence and his
coronavirus emergency team praying for a
solution we are so screwed and this is
why I talk about in my book Church of
cowards in stores now I'm guarantee
Amazon wherever books are sold that we
face mockery and and contempt in our
culture if we practice our faith if we
give evidence of our faith in public
this is the kind of treatment we can
expect to receive now for many
Christians across the world you know
it's it's it's quite it's quite
different it's quite more serious than
that they face not just mockery and
scorn although that as well but along
with that there are machetes and and and
rocks and guns and and and and those
sorts of things we don't we don't really
have to worry about that but even so for
many Christians in this country just the
mockery and the score and the contempt
and the snide comments on on the
internet are enough to make them run for
the hills or better yet run under their
bed or at least to hide their faith
under the bed so nobody sees it so they
don't get made fun of and that's why I
have so much respect for Mike Pence's
unapologetic faith or the unapologetic
faith of anybody but but here's the
point pence is not trying to solve the
coronavirus problem only through prayer
if that's what they were doing I'd be
first in line to criticize if that was
their entire plan they were doing
anything else I I would I would be the
first one to criticize that but that's
not what they're doing they pray and
then they get down to the business of
taking active steps whatever active
steps that they can personally take the
coronavirus is something that must be
approached medically scientifically and
there's nothing about prayer that
precludes that God gave us brains and
expects us to use them he gave us the
capacity for science and medicine
expects us to use them too if you have
cancer God does not want you to sit
around the house not getting treated on
the assumption that he'll heal you in
fact Jesus says don't tempt you not to
tempt God you don't tempt God and that's
and that's kind of what or you don't put
God to the test
rather and that's sort of what that
would be it's saying well you know I
know God that you have provided modern
medicine to us that we could use but I'm
not gonna use that because I'm gonna I'm
gonna put you to the test so I'm gonna
see if you're really gonna heal me
that's not what we're told to do in fact
we are specifically told not to do that
but that's not how most Christians
operate you take the steps you can God
will work in his time in his ways and
you do what you can also so there's no
conflict here there's no problem
and by the way to anyone disturbed by
the sight of people praying over a
medical or scientific issue I've got bad
news I've got really bad news for you
because did you know that most of the
greatest scientific and medical minds in
history have been Christians have been
people who pray so are we gonna throw
Newton's ideas out the window
probably the greatest scientific mind in
history is that his ideas I thought he
was a devout Christian or Pascal or
Galileo or Kepler or Boyle or on down
the list I mean even outside of science
you go to you look at any field the
smartest people the greatest innovators
the greatest pioneers have in many cases
been Christian da Vinci Aquinas
Shakespeare Mozart Washington Martin
Luther King jr. Edison Tesla Alexander
Graham Bell Adam Smith Marconi Dickens
Faulkner Tolkien Marco Polo Neil
Armstrong Magellan Columbus Andrew Ford
on down the list all Christians now none
of this proves in and of itself the
Christianity is true of course but it
does make the snide kindest kind
intention of or condescension I should
say condensation the snide condensation
as well it does make it look rather
silly doesn't it and it does
that Christianity that being devoutly
Christian does not preclude preclude you
from being a great genius or from
accomplishing real things in the areas
of science medicine or any other area in
fact evidence would seem to suggest the
opposite correlation the evidence of
history would seem to testify to the
fact that actually being a Christian
helps you in these areas and it's not
hard to see why that would be the case
especially in science because in
Christianity we know that there's a
purpose and a design and a logic to
everything and with that underlying
foundation you go from there to
discovering exactly what that design is
and how it works so there's again no
contradiction whatsoever and it's just
it's very easy to sit there and say all
these silly Christians praying but if
that's your attitude think of all the
people that you're accusing of being
silly and stupid
all the guys I just listed now we're
gonna move on to some headlines but
first you know Super Tuesday is today
and we want to hear from you so you know
we do enough of the of the punditry and
and and predicting and everything we
want to hear what you think tell us who
you think will win the Democratic
nomination by texting either Biden
Bernie Bloomberg or Warren two eight
three four zero zero and on Tuesday
night during daily wire backstage
they're gonna analyze the results live
again text either Biden Bernie Bloomberg
Warren two eight three four zero zero
and the ant the the results will be
analyzed on daily wire backstage I
noticed that Tulsi Gabbard is not it's
not I mean she could win too so I think
she should be I guess you could text
that also maybe all right um onto
headlines number one Super Tuesday of
course as I just mentioned fourteen
it's voting in their primaries and Joe
Biden is ready for action we need all
these truths to be self-evident all men
are created by the goal you know this
you know the thing and as Martin Luther
King jr. once said I have a a you know
one of those what do you call them
sleepy thought thingies I will say that
if I had if I placed a bet on which
Democratic candidate would be the one to
refer to God as the thing all my money
would have gone on Sanders or maybe
Warren I I never would have guessed
Biden necessarily so I would have lost I
would have lost that bet
and I'm just wondering what which thing
does Biden think is responsible for
creating men and women it could
conceivably be this thing or or one of
these things I'm just wondering which
which thing I maybe I would go with the
hand kind of a hand of God situation
there I'm just trying to understand what
Biden's theology is here now I guess if
you wanted to be to be generous to him
you could you could say that maybe when
he said the thing he wasn't really
referring to god that was more he was he
was referring to the Declaration of
Independence and he was kind of saying
you know the the well you know the rest
of it I don't have to tell you the rest
you know that's the the thing that the
thing that says about the about the
people being created equal I'm not sure
either way this we're really thinking
about putting this guy in the White
House huh it's not gonna get better just
so you know people who start losing
their minds at 78 they don't suddenly
turn it around at 80 it's just it's it's
it's kind it's a one-way ticket
unfortunately and that's what I've been
saying now for months it's we are mortal
beings there are realities there are
limitations that come with being mortal
unfortunately I'm not happy about it and
and and Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders -
they are running up against those
limitations and those limit
should exclude them for the White House
but you know they don't because we've
decided that we could never have a 33
year old in the White House but sure if
you're but a 93 year old sure why not
who could possibly see a problem with
that number two sometimes conspiracy
theories actually pan out so those of
you and I'm in this group who insisted
for years that Apple must have some kind
of self-destruct mechanism in our phones
that makes them stop working or slow
down whenever the new models come out so
that we're forced to go by the new
models well it turns out there may be
some there might be some truth of that
Apple has agreed to pay five hundred
million dollars in a class-action
lawsuit for intentionally slowing down
older phones and in this case the
lawsuit is focused on iPhone 6 and 7 now
they have it admitted they haven't
admitted that they did it for that
reason in fact they haven't admitted
wrongdoing at all but they are gonna pay
out it looks like you know around five
hundred million dollars which means if
you had an iPhone 6 or 7 you just struck
it rich all eligible Apple customers
stand to receive now get ready from
ready for those hope you're sitting down
because your life has changed forever
you receive it says $25 so go for a
splurge at Applebee's get that get the
entree and get the appetizer even if the
appetizer isn't half off or got buy a
pair of jeans at Target you know if
there's a sale you might be able to buy
jeans and socks as well so I mean really
go and enjoy yourself go crazy out there
you've earned it Congrats number three a
guy in the Outer Banks recorded a
time-lapse video of the of the Milky Way
and he recorded it from I guess what
appears to be his makeshift flying
saucer home that he lives it I'm not
really sure what's going on here you'll
see in a second but he captured some
mysterious flying objects in the sky and
this comes only a year after another guy
in the Outer Banks recorded this nothing
in this
at all then all of a sudden
ma'am what is that
maybe I don't know what that is
we're in the middle of the ocean
on a ferry nothing around what
no way no no
this raises the question of why are the
aliens so interested in the Outer Banks
I mean it's nice they're family friendly
nice vacation spot but I'd recommend to
the aliens if you're looking for a beach
on the east coast of the United States I
would look maybe at the Eastern Shore of
Maryland and Delaware you know you've
got Ocean City there Rehoboth doing
Bethany and all within all within you
know 30 or 40 miles so you you know
that's what I would recommend to any
intergalactic visitors of course we have
to entertain the possibility however
remote that these were not aliens and
what you can say in favor of that theory
the non alien theory is that it's
probably physically impossible for any
manned spacecraft to actually travel for
one solar system to another because
because of the vast distances and you
would need to travel at the speed of
light and even if you could do that
which is probably physically impossible
you would still be in the spacecraft for
many years for several years at least
just to get just to get around our local
solar systems and and and you know then
you've got issues of radiation poisoning
everything and as well as all the other
practical problems which means the only
other option would be to use wormholes
to travel from one solar system to
another but we don't even know if
wormholes exist so arguably the more
likely possibility is that the first
video was maybe a drone that somebody
was flying around and the second one was
I'm not really sure what that would be
maybe a whole fleet of giant radioactive
lightning bugs possibility you know you
do see those sometimes number four this
I'm a big fan of Mike Bloomberg was
questioned by a voter yesterday and and
this is how that went how do you justify
pushing for more gun control when you
have an armed security detail that is
likely equipped with the same firearms
and magazines that you seek to ban the
common citizen from owning does your
life matter more than mine or my
families or these people's
look I probably get 40 or 50 threats
every week okay and some of them are
real that just happens when you have a
mayor in New York City or you're very
wealthy and if you're campaigning for
president United States you get lots of
threats so I have a security detail I'd
pay for it all myself and you know
they're they're all retired police
officers who are very well trained in
firearms great question I really it
always frustrates me when I watch these
town halls and voters have a chance to
hold a politician's feet to the fire on
national TV you could say whatever you
want even if the questions are submitted
ahead of time well it's you know you're
there are people recording you might be
on live TV you have the the microphone
so submit a fake question an easy one
and then when you get the mic ask
something hard why aren't you doing that
I think throwing a softball question at
a politician at a town hall is a
betrayal of the American it should lead
to an automatic revocation of your
citizens citizenship rights that's
that's what I would do because it's um
it's it's most people don't get this
chance you get the chance use it well
this man used that chance wisely asked a
simple question but one that gets right
to the to the heart of the matter and
Bloomberg's answer of course was weak as
expected he says well I'm an important
person and I get a lot of threats plus
the people who have guns around me
they're all very well-trained the
problem with that logic is one most avid
gun collectors are very well trained
there are very many people who own
several guns legally and don't know how
to use them if somebody's a you know is
into buying guns it's because they also
like using them whether hunting or at
the at the range or or what-have-you
so they're they're probably well trained
they're probably very knowledgeable and
a lot of them are former military and he
says that he gets a lot of threats well
I'm sure he does as a public figure I'm
not anywhere near as well-known as Mike
but I get threats so I can only imagine
that that it's it's it how it is for
people at Bloomberg's level of
prominence but average people ordinary
Americans face different kinds of
threats they might not get the the kinds
of death threats that famous people get
but um
but they they have different threats
especially if they don't live in gated
mansions they live in neighborhoods
often and in some cases dangerous
neighborhoods so they have their own
reasons to need to protect themselves so
that answer doesn't wash either the the
both of those justifications don't wash
and the real reason of course this is
what Bloomberg can't say but you know
the the guy asked him is your life more
important than mine
Bloomberg's real answer what he's
thinking in his head is yes that that's
actually exactly it I'm more important
than you he can't say that so instead he
grasps for these other straws and it
just doesn't work out number five
finally Chris Matthews host of hardball
and MSNBC made a surprise announcement
on his show last night that he is
leaving effective immediately and here's
how that sounded let me start with my
headline tonight I'm retiring
this is the last hardball and MSNBC and
obviously this isn't for lack of
interest in politics as you can tell
I've loved every minute of my 20 years
as host of hardball every morning I read
the papers and I'm gung ho to get to
work
not many people have had this privilege
I love working with my producers and the
discussions we have over how to report
the news and I love having this connects
with you the good people who watch I've
learned who you are bumping into you on
the sidewalk right waiting in an airport
and say hello you're like me I hear it
from your kids and grandchildren who say
my dad loves you or my grandmother loves
you or my husband watched it till the
end well after a conversation with MSNBC
I decided tonight will be my last
hardball so let me tell you why the
younger generation is out there ready to
take the reins we see them in politics
in the media and fighting for their
causes they are improving the workplace
we're talking here about better
standards than we grow
with fair standards a lot of it has to
do with how we talk to each other
compliments on a woman's appearance that
some men including me might have once
incorrectly thought were okay we're
never okay not then is certainly not
today and for making such comments in
the past I'm sorry now the real reason
for his sudden departure seems to be the
controversies that he's been involved in
recently some of them having to do with
his very controversial stance that he's
articulated that he doesn't think a
socialist should be the Democratic
nominee pretty outrageous can't have
that kind of content on MSNBC these days
he's also been accused of sexual
harassment and this probably is is the
main thing in fact an article was
published by GQ about three days ago two
or three days ago detailing some of his
alleged sexual harassment and the
article starts by accusing Matthews of
of of questioning Elizabeth Warren on
air after a debate last week because
obviously it's totally inappropriate for
a news anchor to ask questions of a
female politician you can't have that
and then it mentions how he has
criticized Hillary Clinton which is also
terribly sexist and then finally he gets
to the sexual harassment or according to
the author very near sexual harassment
that she herself suffered a few years
ago when she was appearing on his show
and she says that she was in the makeup
chair Matthews came in and was
complimenting her appearance and said
that she looks so nice in the makeup
that he's falling in love with her now
this obviously was a joke he wasn't
actually professing his love to her I
don't think that she thinks that he was
being totally serious but it was
flirtatious and that's it you know
that's the extent of the charges that
are made against him and that apparently
led to him being forced out of his show
after 20 years now I'm not a Chris
Matthews fan frankly I don't care if his
show goes off the air or if it's all in
the air doesn't make a difference to me
but this is completely out of hand at
this point completely ludicrous it is
not sexual harassment for a man to
compliment a woman or even to flirt with
her it may not be appropriate but that
doesn't make it harassment for God's
sake
if you don't like the comments that
somebody is making to you then tell the
dude to buzz off you know I really it's
it's all of these women who are in these
awkward situations where someone said
something to them they don't like and
then they they they say nothing at the
time and then they wait and they write
an expose in a magazine about it
years later speak up for yourself
or take it in stride and laugh it off
whatever however you want to respond to
it respond to it but um there are all
kinds of options for responding to a but
but waiting two years and then writing
an article a breathless melodramatic you
know a tell-all article in GQ that just
doesn't seem like the most rational
option and you know what women in the
workplace are flirtatious with men all
the time
women make comments to men all the time
why do we pretend this doesn't happen
why do we pretend this is a one-way
street we all know that it's not women
do this too and when they do the man is
expected to take it in stride to brush
it off if he cries about it
if he acts traumatized if he wants if he
goes running to the press and says oh my
gosh a woman flirted with me let me tell
you about it we would all laugh at him
we all would and we know we would so I'm
sick of this double standard it's it's
it's bogus and it cannot be justified
and don't tell me it's different because
men are physically imposing they might
be I don't think Chris Matthews is very
physically imposing but but but some men
might be but was this lady worried that
Chris Matthews would physically assault
her in the makeup room of the studio is
was she concerned about that I don't
think she was I think that she was
worried about responding harshly to
someone who is important in her industry
and also it was just awkward which is
why she waited to stand up bravely
courageously until Chris Matthews you
know until his star had already started
fading and he was kind of on the outs
and people were again
because of the stuff with Bernie Sanders
and that's when she comes out and says
okay now I have a story to tell
very courageous but that concern of
professional awkwardness or
embarrassment can also be felt by men if
a woman is is is coming on to a man and
the man says I'm uncomfortable with this
this is inappropriate
he might be worried about the reaction
that that people will have it might make
him into a laughingstock if word gets
out that he responded that way to a
woman flirting with him but does that
make him a victim of harassment does
that does that mean that he needs
therapy for PTSD now no and nobody would
accept that from a man everybody would
just say hey get over it in fact there
have and I'm not this is not me making
this up
there have been men who have come out
with with stories about women that are
in this vein and nobody cares in fact
there was um I think it was a bodyguard
of a top man that he was a bodyguard of
Mariah Carey I believe who came out last
year two years ago and said that he was
sexually harassed nobody cared
no no one cared everyone just died about
whatever it would such a blatant double
standard with this and we all just
accept it like it's normal like you know
what yeah women have a diff different
rules women can say what they want
different rules for women no you know
what you guys on the Left you're the
ones who say men and women are the same
okay then one standard one standard you
don't get to one alright moving on for
your daily cancellation we have a simple
and quick one Reuters is canceled and
and well deserved I think like I said
for the second time as you can see from
this headline in picture it says in a
Texas chicken joint Biden and one-time
rival Budaj unite to stop Sanders few
problems here big problems first of all
that's not a Texas just chicken joint
that's a what a burger which is which is
first of all a burger joint not a
chicken joint it says it right there in
the title of the restaurant also it's
not exclusive to Texas
so calling what a burger
a Texas chicken joint it's like it's
like calling McDonald's a Vermont coffee
shop now it does sell coffee bad coffee
and they are in Vermont but that you
know it still it doesn't really make a
lot of sense and then of course the
other big problem is that that's not
Buddha judge obviously that is Luke
Wilson so for that reason Reuters is
cancelled we're gonna move on to emails
in just a second but you know Super
Tuesday has finally come upon us as
we've been discussing and maybe we
should call it super socialist Tuesday I
think might be a better term because the
Democrats are ready to nominate an
actual socialist to go up against the
president come with the Democrats
pushing a socialist agenda it's best
that you take advantage of all the
savings you can get this is capitalism
at work okay not socialism so right now
we're offering 25% off all daily why our
membership plans when you use a coupon
code never socialist that's the coupon
code never socialist there's really no
better way to help out the working-class
over the Daily wire then becoming a
member daily wire members get an ad-free
website experience access to all of our
live broadcasts show library full three
hours of been Shapiro you get all the
the bells and whistles op-eds from Ben
Shapiro as well exclusive to members you
can join us for special events like like
the Super Tuesday episode of daily wire
backstage which will happen tonight
along with all of us of course you get
the majestic singular leftist tears
tumblr you get all of that and you get
to stick it to the socialists as well
that's 25% off on daily our memberships
for all plans using Como coupon code
never socialist go to daily wired.com
slash subscribe okay going to emails and
as I said this is now more of a why I'm
wrong segment and what I am asking for
especially send an email Matt wall show
at gmail.com you can send an email for
any reason but the ones I'm especially
interested in are the ones where you're
telling me why I'm wrong about something
whether it's on the show or something
that I wrote or a tweet doesn't matter
and I am gonna argue with you I'm not
just gonna let not gonna leave it at
that because I'm an argumentative
bastards like I wouldn't be but I but I
will at least read it and give you a
chance give give the other side a chance
to be heard so a couple emails in that
vein this is from Marcus says dear Matt
I disagree with your comparison between
the human body and soul and the jar and
liquid of the kool-aid man you asked can
he the kool-aid man live on in liquid
form without the jar I have hope and
faith that he can the problem is you're
assuming that the kool-aid man's jar is
analogous to the human body and that the
liquid is analogous to the human soul
however this is not the case the
fundamental problem with your analogy is
that the body does not contain the soul
but rather does the soul contain the
body and make it one as Aquinas says in
Summa theologia of course the word
contained should be understood
understood metaphorically here as the
soul is non-spatial Aquinas this point
is that it's the soul which affects
matter to make the body one thing both
now and over time the body does not
affect the soul in any such way likewise
it is the jar which ensures the unity of
the kool-aid man's liquid and of the
kool-aid man himself the liquid does not
ensure the unity of the jar we could
also put it like this the soul is the
form of the body now what is the form of
the kool-aid man the jar or the Amorphis
uncharred liquid the question answers
itself I think CS Lewis gives us an
especially poetic way of understanding
this question inspired by Platonism he
portrays the spiritual domain as more
solid than the material domain well if
that's so that I ask you which is more
solid the solid jar or the liquid liquid
of the kool-aid man okay I understand
your point but I I will see your Aquinas
and raise you Agustin who said the soul
which is spirit cannot dwell in dust it
is carried along to dwell in the blood
now I believe that he meant this has
metaphor not that the soul is literally
in the blood but that the soul is not
spatially limited is not is not rigid
and static so now let's look at the
kool-aid man let's look at him from a
nigga's Tinian perspective what do you
think represents his blood
metaphorically and thus his soul
metaphorically well G might it be all
that red liquid inside him the point
here again is not that the blood is
literally the soul or that the liquid
and the kool-aid man is literally his
soul you know I don't know if the
kool-aid man has an immortal soul and
neither do you the fact is that that he
appears to be conscious and that might
lead you to the conclusion that he has
one but all he really does is burst
through the door and serve beverages do
you need to have the inner experience
and an awareness of consciousness to do
that probably not
in any case what I'm saying is that you
know all we can do is draw analogies
between the kool-aid man and a human
person but it's not a one-to-one
comparison I think that's where your
that that's where your getting hung up
here at the end of the at the end of the
day I maintain and I think you would
agree the kool-aid man's essence is a
unity of jarring liquid you're trying to
decide which is preeminent which drives
the other but that's just the wrong way
of looking at it would the kool-aid man
be the kool-aid man without the liquid
no it would just be a jar would he be
the kool-aid man without the jar no and
I think perhaps that's all we need to
say on the subject but thank you for
that email and this is from Nate this is
an email from last week talking about
the issue we discussed last week on the
show of the the young six-year-old girl
that was arrested at her school for
hitting a teacher and I was very much
against the arrest I got a lot of emails
telling me why I'm wrong in my position
on that I wanted to read one of them
because I don't get a chance to read
anything about this is from Nate says
dear Matt as an educator for seven years
let me give you a few examples of when
it wouldn't be acceptable for the police
officer to teach this girl a lesson the
teachers and administrators didn't warn
the parents of her behavior there
weren't consequences for her behaviors
in the past the teachers or anyone else
in the room is allowed to touch the girl
and remove her from the room in it and
it not be considered a form of abuse the
main teacher is allowed to grab the
student herself and remove her from the
room if these are in place there would
be no reason for them to ever call the
police my hunch is they're not allowed
to do any of those things you have to
understand the teachers and everybody
else in the schools have very limited
opportunities to be allowed to control
violent behavior no matter what the age
if none of this is in place for the
benefit and sake of the other children
something must be done
furthermore you talk about how traumatic
it is I'm not sure what the worst thing
could happen in this girl other than wow
I shouldn't be doing this or else I'll
get thrown in jail there might be such a
thing as a traumatic experience that
could teach a positive lesson about
physically harming others well Nate you
know I'm just not buying your reasoning
here at all first of all
worst-case scenario if a child that age
is being a disruption and you can't
carry on with teaching because of it and
that does happen well then you call the
child's guardian and you have the
Guardian take them out of the school you
don't call the police and have her
cuffed and sent to the detention center
to get a mug shot taken and be charged
with criminal assault at the age of six
now if there's no guardian that is
available to pick up the kid then you
segregate her you'd send it to the
principal's office or something whatever
happened to that send to the principal's
office
not to send them to jail
now obviously there could be really
extreme situations where maybe the
police do need to step in for
everybody's safety extreme situations
now a six-year-old girl hitting somebody
is not an extreme situation but in very
extreme situations somebody has a weapon
or something obviously in that case you
uh the police may need to step in but
even then you're not gonna charge a
six-year-old girl who's you know she's
been out of diapers for like three years
okay that's how mature she is they're
not gonna charge her with a crime using
that you you you you you know you have
to again you might have to take her out
of the situation you bring her to you
might have to bring her to a facility
depending on the situation but you get
her treatment in that case it's not if
you're not charging her with a crime at
the age of six now as for your claim
that sometimes the best way to teach a
child is a lesson is to cause them
trauma all I can say Nate is that I'm
glad you're not my children's teacher
because that attitude is extremely
concerning you don't teach kids lessons
by traumatizing them that's not how kids
learn the whole point is that very young
children lack the emotional and
psychological tools and development to
control themselves fully and to express
themselves the way that we can you are
impeding that process by causing trauma
trauma does not help in a child's
emotional growth it impedes it you know
fear and and and violence are not ways
to teach kids and you know you know you
don't want a six year old girl to be
afraid that every time she breaks a rule
she's gonna get arrested maybe you want
her to be concerned that if she breaks a
rule in school she'll it'll be punished
you'll have to
right I mean when I was a kid they made
you they like things like you'd have to
write a hundred sentences or something
like that maybe you're worried about
that you're worried about getting sent
to the principal's office you're worried
about getting in trouble at home okay
that's different but no you don't want a
60 to coerce good behavior out of a
child with the fear of criminal
prosecution the best you could hope for
in that case is that they're gonna
behave simply because they're terrified
and in but that's and that might be good
for you it's convenient for you because
well at least they're behaving it's not
good for the child and in the long run
you have not helped this child you know
get become well-adjusted and in the long
run you're gonna end up with worse
behavioral problems that you were then
you would have had otherwise
this is the same attitude that some
parents of teachers have that lead to
kids being drugged where you're putting
seven-year-old boys on on these on these
psychotropic drugs because they're not
you know because it's convenient for you
and in it and it neuters them
effectively mentally it's a good mental
neutering that happens and so it makes
it easier for you it makes it makes them
easier to manage it's not good for the
kid there's no way it's good for a
seven-year-old to be on on psychiatric
medicine that's minced messing with his
brain in ways that we don't even
understand so any doctor who says oh
it's perfectly safe to give these kids
drugs that doctor is lying and I know
he's lying because he doesn't actually
know exactly how this is going to affect
the kid or what the long-term effects
are going to be because we don't
understand everything about the human
brain or how it develops especially in a
child so you couldn't possibly really
know that it's not gonna have any
negative long-term effects you couldn't
possibly know that you're just hoping
you're guessing and I don't
gets right to do last thing I'll say is
when I hear teachers justify this kind
of thing on the basis that teaching is
hard and I don't know what it's like so
I have no room to judge I'm sorry
I I just I have no patience for that I
have a I have a lot of sympathy for
teachers who are doing the best they can
I know that it is a hard job and so I've
all the sympathy in the world and all
the admiration and respect for good
teachers but teachers who are bad and
tried to justify their you know
ineffectiveness and they're they're you
know incompetence on the basis that it's
such a hard job you don't know what it's
like it's so hard that's where I lose
all sympathy for the same reason that if
you hired someone a roofer to fix your
roof in July well you know what fixing a
roof in July is is a really hard job
it's dangerous it's it's physically
demanding I mean you don't know what
it's like have you ever been on a roof
for for six hours a day in July I
haven't been but and you have all the
sympathy in the world for for people
that do that job you have all the
admiration and respect in the world for
people to do that job because we need
people to do it you know so thank God
for them but if you hire a roofer and he
does a terrible job and your roof
collapses because of it and you call him
up to tell him and he says but it's so
hard you don't know what it's like it's
such a hard job you're gonna say shut up
you whiny baby I don't want to hear that
I paid you to do this job I pay you and
paid to do it don't cry about it you
don't want to do it don't do it I paid
you to do the job you didn't do it right
now my roof has collapsed so you know
the moment he starts justifying that by
whining all your sympathies are at the
window and it should be well I say the
same thing with people that work with
our kids the moment you justify hurting
kids and I think if you're justifying
arresting six-year-old kids you're
you're justify hurting them the moment
you justify that on the basis that it's
hard I don't want to hear it any more
than I want to hear from parents being a
parent is hard but if your
hurting your child and you're neglecting
and abusing them I don't want to hear
your complaints about hard how hard it
is because you know what there are
millions of parents out there who also
have it hard but managed to do the job
without abusing or neglecting their kids
I expect you to do the same
there are many teachers out there who do
the job despite how hard it is um
without you know having to have their
students shipped away in handcuffs at
the age of six so it can be done I
expect you to do it if you can't do it
you don't want to do it don't take on
the job I think that's a very fair
perspective all right and we will leave
it there thank you though for the for
those emails Matt well show at gmail.com
Matt well show at gmail.com Church of
cowards in stores now go to Amazon buy
it have a great day Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]